die letzte Wahl in diesem Krisenjahr und
drei Lehren daraus erstens die SPD kann
gewinnen ein beliebter Amtsträger
sympathisch und glaubwürdig macht das
Rennen das ist klassisch für eine
Landtagswahl bei der sich die Menschen
zumal in Krisenzeiten hinter dem
vertrauten versammeln wenn sie ihm denn
Vertrauen Olaf Scholz im Kanzleramt wird
durch das Wahlgeschenk aus Hannover ein
Stück weit entlastet sollte daraus aber
keinen allzu großen Vertrauensbeweis in
seine Person ableiten Stefan weil hat
mehr trotz als wegen Olaf Scholz
gewonnen
zweitens die CDU kann mit Attacke auf
die Ampel nichts gewinnen und ist längst
nicht so stark wie es der
Bundesvorsitzende März proklamiert nicht
die Stärke der CDU wird der Berliner
Ampel gefährlich sondern die Schwäche
der FDP für die Liberalen geht ein
katastrophales Wahljahr zu Ende dem
Vorsitzenden Lindner ist es nie gelungen
das Versprechen an seine Welle
einzulösen Korrektiv für Rot-Grün zu
sein der grüne Erfolg übrigens sieht
größer aus als er ist im Plus schlummert
auch ein harbeck-dämpfer sagen wir es so
Schwein gehabt
und schließlich drittens die große
Mehrheit in Niedersachsen hat die
demokratische Mitte gewählt doch Krieg
und Krise werden bedrohlicher davon
profitiert die AFD gegen explodierende
Energiepreise und Inflation braucht es
jetzt konkrete Konzepte keine
Beruhigungspillen in comic-sprache denn
wo soll das hinführen so ein Wahlabend
im Ductus des doppelwumms Klänge dann so
FDP am Boden Carbon CDU geknickt zack
grüne weniger stark als gedacht Boing
AFD ojemine und die ampelperspektive
Bumm Krach Peng im Ernst bitte nicht die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wollen und
brauchen Antworten der Wahlkampf ist
vorbei jetzt bitte dringend zur Sache es
eilt